à moins de deux mois du scrutin la
tension est palpable en centrafrique
le pays fait face à une insécurité
grandissante à la tête de cette ancienne
colonie française depuis 2016 après des
élections générales
faustin archange touadéra a déposé sa
candidature pour la prochaine
présidentielle au sein de la population
c'est l'inquiétude qui prédomine le plus
dur maintenant c'est de faire en sorte
que ça se passe dans la paix sinon notre
plus grande inquiétude c'est pour nos
compatriotes qui sont dans province dans
les villages comme il ya un problème
d'insécurité car on ne sait pas comment
auront lieu ces élections pour choisir
les nouvelles autorités
il faut que tous les centrafricains pris
beaucoup dieu pour que ces élections se
passent bien
c'est dieu qui a fait que ça aura lieu
parce que comme ces élections auront
lieu fin décembre
il faudra prier pour qu'il ne se passe
rien de grave des habitants qui
réclament donc plus de garanties
concernant l'organisation de ces
élections
l'opposant crespin m'bolhi goumba à la
tête d'un groupe de sept députés mène
une campagne essentiellement axé sur
cette insécurité redouté par la
population et sa formation politique
il ya quelques jours mon secrétaire
général à cabo le secrétaire général de
la confédération de mon parti a été
froidement assassiné
il rejoint la longue liste de ceux qui
ont été assassinés dans ce pays depuis
quelques années déjà
prenons la libération du sol national
évidemment et je suis une cible
je suis conscient de cette situation
mais cette situation qui est partagé
aussi par tous les autres candidats
les trois quarts du territoire
centrafricain sont actuellement
contrôlées par des groupes armés malgré
la présence de près de onze mille
soldats de l'onu une situation qui
conviendra à l'actuel chef de l'état
selon certains opposants
naturellement quand on est parti au
pouvoir on bénéficie de la propre
protection de l'état et d'une certaine
compréhension
je dois le dire de la part des grandes
herbes et c'est notoire donc des
videmment nous sommes très inquiets nous
sommes inquiets et nous voulons bien
aller aux élections qu'à preuve nous
avons déposé nos différents dossiers
hier auprès de l'agencé nationale des
élections maintenant
avant d'arriver à ces élections il est
très important que nous nous asseyons et
que nous définissions des conditions
dans lesquelles ces élections doivent
avoir lieu si les jeux ne sont pas
encore faits observateurs et analystes
prédisent une réélection du président
touadéra reste à savoir si une coalition
de l'opposition est envisageable pour
l'empêcher d'effectuer un second mandat